you know I might go out and do some you
know different things you know watch
hasbin Hotel the other day uh wait what
yeah is is it good
um I am not the target audience for okay
I don't know anything about this I know
the name and the fan base is kind of
notorious I I don't yeah I have no I
known nothing about it but all I see is
that people get pissed off about Twitter
I don't know about what I see people get
pissed off and I don't know what cuz it
nothing I don't know anything about
what's going on on Twitter I mean
Twitter pissed off again is piss off
like no but I feel that's one of those
fan bases where you hear so often and
the only times I hear about it is
because some controversy happening
within the community I have no idea yeah
I have no idea I can understand maybe
why because you know this this kind of
show um I think that with how many eyes
it has on it and the kind of people that
you know this kind of show attracts
there's a lot of there's going to be a
lot of discussions about a lot of things
especially on a platform like Twitter um
I came into it because Sydney showed me
the pilot [__] years ago I'm like oh
that's that's that's pretty cool I'm not
really like musicals aren't really my
thing actually I might I might slowly be
see I didn't even know it was a musical
yeah yeah so so okay here here's the
thing it's kind of like it it it selling
point is that it's an adult musical kind
of like it's an adult animated musical
right about these you know characters in
hell that uh want to get promoted to
Heaven basically and that's kind of like
it's kind of cool con kind of like the
elevator pitch it's got a really cool
aesthetic I really like the aesthetic um
and you know I wasn't really into
musicals until I saw Hamilton with daus
and Emily and I didn't like it at first
and then I just found myself continually
quoting it every so often D Hamilton is
such a good
musical it's like unironically a bang of
musical don't really like musicals I
don't really like musicals either I'm
picking choosing with musicals but
Hamilton was good Hamilton I think
worked for me cuz it just felt like like
a meme you
know that's why almost I didn't want to
watch it cuz it felt so people were so
upset about everything like they were
cuz they like it so much and they were
getting so angry about people not liking
it and I was like man dude the raps are
fire though I will say that the songs
are kind of fire but they're also kind
of funny at the same time like there's
this one song in Hamilton where it's
it's the a song that revolves entirely
around writing essays right and they try
to Hype up this moment where like okay
Hamilton wrote all of these documents
and like they were like okay we're
writing we're writing these essays all
right we're writing these documents we
split into three people all right this
guy he wrote five essays this guy he
wrote 10 essays and then everything like
and then he pauses for a second and then
Hamilton wrote 21 essays I can't
remember the exact number but I remember
hearing that and the moment it's propped
up at this moment being like oh [__]
man's can
right I I don't know it's it's it's just
the right amount of campiness that it's
like if it's like if your English
teacher was in a rap battle you know
like but you wrote 21 essays you're weak
oh all these like dudes in like 17th
16th century clothing just be like oh
[__] yeah it's so funny so I don't know
like I at the beginning I I walked out
of Hamilton and I'm like yeah it was all
right and then like I keep I keep
thinking about certain moments in it and
I'm like okay that's a lot of it to come
wor something yeah so I ended up
watching a bit of hasbin hotel with
Sydney cuz we were both like curious
about it um and one thing it made me
realize right cuz I said as I said it me
it's meant to be like an adult musical
sure uh so there is a lot of swearing in
it okay um and it made me realize how
weird it is to hear especially like an
American you're going to say this an
American piece of media like a fictional
media with so much swearing in it sure
and I don't know I I kind of didn't like
it really cuz CU like doesn't suit the
American I don't dialect as well you
know sometimes you hear a sitcom and
what about like South
Park that is a lot of swearing is
it I feel like southp kind of works cuz
it's
kids in a weird way it feels like I
could believe 13-year-old kids wanting
to swear all the [__] time yeah I
think they're like 10 in the show oh
yeah actually they are I feel like it's
so Preposterous and so ridiculous that
it works I don't know because like own
weird sometimes I hear like I see like a
[__] guy Richie film or something and
you know it it it works for something
like that you hear it in like a British
IR the UK yeah yeah it just adds I don't
know it adds character to it whereas you
know with just a neutral American accent
like if you like if you see like a New
York accent or Boston accent all right
I'm like okay that fits but just like a
neutral American accent that you'd
normally hear on like a Saturday morning
cartoon sure and you're hearing like
characters say [__] and I remember there
was one moment where one of the
characters Dropped a seab Bomb and me
and C just me and C just like we
literally just like felt it in our
bodies we like oh we just shuted oh oh
did you did you hear the filthy language
that is definitely huh is it's just
right uh so I've seen the first three
episodes yeah it's all right fair enough
if you're into musicals I think that
this definitely uh you know I can't wait
for the hasman hotel community and
defend themselves I don't I don't
[__] care dude I mean I don't care
either I don't think also people who
watch on YouTube give a [__] I think
sometimes sometimes our Clips find their
way on Twitter and people like what the
[__] did these guys
say yeah I mean the reason we ended up
watching it was because of that big uh
big meme of that one YouTuber who paid
50k oh my God Hotel animation oh my okay
okay conspiracy theory
time that controversy came out just as
hasbin Hotel was being released like you
think it was an inside job I don't know
is it an inside job I don't know man I
think the story probably took up cuz
people were probably very interested in
hasbin hotel and probably just was like
the vend diagram of [__] interesting
weird story to pop off I remember I
remember our friend D sent me that on
Discord and he was just in all CS he
just said what is blood
doing
I props to him I mean dude if you got 50
bands to spend on
gooning I think respect I'm like it
wasn't it wasn't even hardcore it wasn't
even hardcore um likeon is wild it was
like a like a like a Mariah Carey music
video it was like it was just sensual
enough for some people you know yeah
yeah just was it YouTube safe it's just
about YouTube just about on the cosp but
it was because of that that me and S got
curious and I was just like wait a
minute wait this just released like
today as all of this that's interesting
because I had the opposite effect of
that where I watch that and I'm like I'm
not watching this show if this is if
this is what the result of that show is
and that fan base is not to say all the
fan Bas like that but you know I think
you know Standalone like kind of
controversies like that in any kind of
like media franchise you know fan base
like when that [__] pops out you're kind
of just like I'm sure this is an
exception but it had to come from
somewhere right so I it makes me afraid
to like step into that fan base
immediately from there but I mean like
huge props to to the Creator because the
creator of hasbin Hotel I mean seeing I
the only reason I know about hasbin
hotel is basically because of Sydney um
and just you know seeing like her work
of on this for years since like
finishing art college or something cuz
she's about like our age I think right
uh she started off I think I don't know
the entire law of hasman hotel but I
know she either posted her work on
Tumblr or early YouTube and it just
[__] blew up hell yeah and seeing
seeing like a content creator you know
just with pure passion work on this one
project for ages and be able to sell it
to Amazon Prime and still have like a
big hand in it I know there's there was
a lot of controversies for whatever
reason H maybe they're just getting
angry about stuff for the sake of
getting angry but I know that they did I
think when they when it went to Amazon
they replaced the whole cast yeah they
did which I think annoyed a lot of
people as well yeah um which is
understandable I mean that's generally
not a good move to do but I'm not sure
sometimes shows have requirements that
could be like hey everyone has to be
Union or hey I don't know why seems odd
but hey it is what it is hey still ended
up being successful right I I watched a
musical I didn't know it was a musical I
I watched the new Wily Wonga movie oh is
that a musical I I did I didn't I've
watched the original I completely I
never think of whitly woner as a mus
yeah I never think a yeah same here I a
lot of musical
and so I watched it and surprisingly
pretty good Timothy
sham okay actually not to not to be that
guy he's I I felt like he was the
weakest part of the film I don't know if
I'm crazy I I just Wonka is a weird guy
to me and he plays him as like this kind
of could do nothing wrong fun happy guy
and I feel like woner in the original
film The June Wilder film is such a
[__] weird you've all watched it
right yeah he's such a weird dude Jean
wer and he comes off as almost like not
not Sinister but like he's a he's a kind
of [__] up dude in the film oh yeah uh
like his his he kills children
yeah he's very he's a child murderer
it's like he's kind of a just an
uncomfort like I think we all know
someone or met someone who's like really
nice but also kind of make gives you a
weird vibe and I feel like that's what
Wonka would be in real life like you're
like I don't know why Wonka gives me the
creeps but there should be a creep there
but uh the cast is really good W of the
kind of Dude to like laugh at awkward
situations you you know the the main bad
guy is the is John from Peep Show and
he's so good yeah he's so good there's
so many really good British actors that
I
love Hugh gr Olivia Coleman isn't itan
uh the actors are really good but yeah
Hugh Grant plays the Umpa limpa which is
uh which is an interesting choice and
then Keegan Michael key is in that yeah
yeah yeah can you type in Hugh Grant
umpalumpa it's very bizarre yeah I saw
it in the trailer [__] weird like I I
remember the first time I saw this
trailer cuz Aki really wanted to watch
it I I did [__] Double Take when I
saw Hugh Grant cuz he's right at the end
of the trailer I was just like that's an
odd Choice going for Hugh Grant and
making him uh I love it I look at him
yeah I don't understand this choice but
hey it was it was cool and it was fun I
liked I actually kind of liked hukan as
this character but it did strike me as
kind of odd he's like a
gigachad yeah well he's kind of like a
[__] Navy SEAL jack of all trades in
this movie for some reason right um but
it was a fun movie uh nonetheless much
better than I thought it was going to be
and you know what it was dead there was
no I I I was just me in this movie
theater really and it was like the week
it released in Japan so I guess they
have no [__] interest in this I don't
think Willie woner is even like a a well
established character that Japanese
people know of well here's what's funny
is that I asked my Japanese friend I was
like hey do you like do you want to go
watch the new you w film and they were
like oh uh yeah I've seen the original I
really like um Jack not Jack blackout um
uh Johnny Depp I really like Johnny Depp
in the original I was like that's not
the original no no I was like that's not
the original and then it occurred to me
that most people only know Willie Wonka
from Johnny Depp the Tim Burton film
yeah they only know that version they
didn't even know there was the Gen wild
version which to be honest compared to
the Gene Wilder version not that great
in my opinion yeah I mean I haven't
watched seen the Gene Wilder version I
think most people in America and the UK
have only watched the G which which is
very iconic well it's because like as
much as I like Johnny I don't think he
was a very good I I I don't know I think
the the Johnny Depp woner film just felt
too much like a Tim Burton film you know
what I mean where it's like it was so
iconically Tim Burton that you're like
oh yeah I forgot this is a [__] Wily
woner film